(LAUGHS)
Look at you.
You all fucked up.
Clear your mind.
Let yourself fall away.
Breathe in...
breathe out.
(INHALES, EXHALES)
(INHALES SHARPLY)
Breathe in your mouth.
Exhale through your ass.
You know how to fuckin'
breathe, don't you?
I don't gotta tell you
how to breathe.
That shit is involuntary.
Picture yourself walking along
in a meadow.
A stream flows by.
Damn, streams are sexy.
Carrying away your worries
and all your fuckin' fears.
(INHALES DEEPLY)
(EXHALES)
While your eyes are closed, you
don't see the fuckin' reality.
And you
in your mama's basement...
on that stupid-ass,
dirty-ass couch.
You should have a full-sized
couch, but you don't.
You're sleepin'
on a fuckin' loveseat.
You gotta fold your body in half
and lay the fuck down
on that bitch.
Yeah, your life is fucked up.
Center yourself.
Get your fuckin' life back.
Close your eyes and imagine
where the fuck you at.
Go back to that meadow.
A bird chirps in the distance.
But not one of those
annoying-ass birds
that never shuts the fuck up.
Cockatoo, or a fuckin' parrot
or some shit like that.
I'm talking about
a nice, relaxin'-ass bird.
A fuckin' bird that just
sits the fuck there
and just looks at yo' ass.
That what the fuck he's doing.
Not buggin' you,
not gettin' on your
fuckin' nerves,
not taking you some place
where you don't need to be.
Look at him.
He's beautiful.
Look that-- Ooh, ooh,
look at that bird!
Oh. There's a whole lot of 'em.
Think of something that
brings you joy.
A butterfly.
A fuckin' butterfly.
A warm ray of sunshine.
Titties.
Fuckin' titties.
You know what you like.
(INHALES DEEPLY)
(EXHALES)
Keep breathin'.
In through your nose.
Out through your ass.
(INHALES)
In through your nose.
Out... through your ass.
Keep goin'. Keep breathing.
In through your nose,
Out through your ass.
Yeah, keep goin'.
Keep goin'.
Now, get the fuck out of here.